[Applaudissements]
bonsoir comment ça va
un bonheur d'avoir
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de dossiers
sur Cyril électroniques comme chaque
semaine on commence par quoi
[Musique]
il faut que je boive
michto qui cherche la Moula cette année
c'est
[Applaudissements]
elle ne vous mettra jamais dans la merde
on pourrait tous les deux dans un
[Rires]
Coupe des nations à trouver des
problèmes à chaque fois que je comprends
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention écoutez bien l'extrait qui va
suivre attaque d'animaux
une chose est sûre Jean-Mi a toujours
réponse à tout
[Musique]
c'est qu'il n'a jamais les choses comme
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez toujours le maître est
l'enfant de Gilles et Isabelle me l'a
fait
attention enfants vieux à venir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
joue le petit conseil ne présente jamais
votre
[Applaudissements]
Isabelle à Sandhamn la définition du mot
quitté l'émission
personne personne parce que la seule
personne seule personne à qui sont
livrés les personnes
[Applaudissements]
je vois pas pourquoi
la France envie de savoir le dire
franchement
[Rires]
justement parce que j'aimerais
j'aimerais
que vous sortez pour trouver l'âme sœur
bien sûr vous l'avez déjà trouvé
Kinder Kinder non je mange des kinder
pour l'instant oui
des questions
[Rires]
aujourd'hui je n'ai rien à dire rien
[Applaudissements]
un très bon.
J'ai l'impression que vous êtes sur le
point de faire crac-crac bistouquette
avec
[Musique]
soir d'automne Cyril Hanouna fait une
déclaration qui allait bouleverser TPMP
[Musique]
à ton tour pour rendre jaloux Cyril
Matthieu Delormeau protectime relation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
intérieur cuisine
[Rires]
mais où Cyrille va-t-il chercher tout ça
quoi qu'il en soit la tentative de
rendre jaloux Baba n'a pas très bien
fonctionné vous êtes amoureux
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Baba ne semble pas indifférent à la
proposition cavalière de Matthieu qui en
profite alors pour se concilier
[Musique]
Mathieu vois clair dans le jeu de Cyril
auraient-ils percer son secret
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cœur de Cyril semble ouvert à
Matthieu Delormeau vivre ont-ils une
belle histoire d'amour et il s'est
installé dans le petit pied-à-terre de
Baba à Los Angeles et surtout le petit
Delormeau verra t-il le jour réponse
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
heureusement ça n'arrivera jamais j'aime
beaucoup Mathieu il peut venir quand il
veut j'aimerais bien
là-bas il
y a beaucoup de gens
très gentil
je trouve qu'il a beaucoup beaucoup de
charme il est très beau
[Applaudissements]
importune sur ta sexualité
[Rires]
la
[Musique]
semaine dernière
Guillaume
on se rappelle
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est bon
merci
alors le prochain métaux je peux mentir
c'est pas le top mais c'est un petit
délire qu'on a eu à la réaction et
concerne si je vous dis
je veux pas vous mentir on a rien
compris donc si vous avez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non non non non c'est énervé après
[Rires]
j'aime pas du tout les garçons
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'avoue que ça m'a
merci
c'est pas possible
je crois que
vraiment tu es
un vrai travail
mais
[Rires]
est-ce qu'on peut dire
ta
gueule.
[Rires]
dans une cage
[Musique]
chien qui le chien qui aboie ne mord pas
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai que moi aussi je
m'occupe un peu de vous comment ça va
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça va de choses très sérieuses comme le
terrorisme et ça va aussi jusqu'au les
films des testicules
confinement dans son compte que vu qu'on
est autant sur l'appli tu es un appart
et aller dans un
[Applaudissements]
il respecte trop justement il a pas
besoin de fiche
ce soir j'ai la chance d'avoir votre
grand-mère ma Dalton
[Applaudissements]
comme une grenouille
vous êtes déjà découvert un bon après de
particulier vraiment
dans un domaine à part la médiocrité
[Applaudissements]
et les autres
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]